we is surely the big fan of Queens
gambit is from Poland oh yeah 96 okay
but now we all know that we can never
trust this guy anymore so after the 40
plays 35 behind I've seized so I
wouldn't give him any money
this is very wrong coming it's written D
45 and you never do D 45
awful awful behavior shame on you
can we castle let's set up a risky
remove okay
too risky this is less risky and then
I'm a risky primo F is coming okay for
ya this mark nickname but especially
smart when you play another opening okay
that's very very sound only way fixing
the piece pawn structure here so he not
going for somebody five premiums I also
approach folio he five all right so
let's play as play in solid weight just
rage as much as we can trade and draw as
many games as as we are able to draw
okay
fruitful mosquito fruitful mosquito
going down
let's go here and now the performance
people come on I'm getting so popular
these days here every mosquito is coming
after me here that's it's annoying
because I think I've had the same
problem against the MV l s MV l last
round the chess table masters it's like
I think I got like 10
I counted 10 francs because at some
point I wanted I wanted to calculate it
till till the end find a wing but he
said that that I was like too busy
fighting for my life or Bishop e6 that
was unexpected such a good move a
fruitful month no jobs jobs aside
so let's centralized until it too late
yeah okay I was using aim but for sure
and eh not going to blunder a Queen
Queen retreats probably okay I can only
think I can hope for is winning b7 poem
otherwise I'm not so okay of course I'm
better but nothing very very serious
you saw that mosquito in the MV all game
okay it was like not a single one I
think it was a lot of what do they just
take it for a fruitful poem okay then
just age for I can also take another
fruitful poem I just show me again let's
take a first for occurs then what I
think we can take here first
oh yeah like this night on if work even
even Kaspar for stated that okay this
night on a forests like more war fee
than even your probably when you're
coming in attacking position so let's
see okay
let's collect just all the polls and see
if punishment comes I'm getting curious
so balls were fruitful but the
punishment is probably are inevitable
but no no I can [ __ ] him I can [ __ ] him
that's my that's my strategy call that
game between see six another one he's
clearly coming for me
okay let's thirty-five now I'm going to
take a free poem the most fruitful pawn
of the universe okay now I'm safe the
porn was juice I prefer the juicy word
and now of course we trade Queens that's
today and I think okay I think a six is
the move Bishop the five sneaky but I I
saw what you did there no no this is
ninety five we leave a check with a
check one extra check o you thank you
for the game d45 c-46 but I expected
another opening from you actually